you mentioned the three r's of computer
vision
are recognition reconstruction
reorganization
can you describe these three r's sure
how they interact
yeah so uh so recognition is the easiest
one
because that's uh what i think
people generally think of as computer
vision
uh achieving these days which is uh
labels so is this a cat is this a dog is
this
chiva i mean you know it could be very
fine grain
like you know specific breed of a dog or
a specific species or bird
or it could be very abstract like animal
but given a part of an image or a whole
image
say put a label on that yeah so that's
that's recognition reconstruction
is uh essentially
it you can think of it as inverse
graphics
i mean that's one way to think about it
so graphics is your you have some
internal computer representation
and uh you have a computer
representation of some objects arranged
in a scene
and what you do is you produce a picture
you produce the pixels corresponding to
a rendering of that scene
so uh so let's
do the inverse of this we are given an
image and we try to
we we we say oh this image arises
from some objects in a scene
looked at with a camera from this
viewpoint and we might have more
information about the objects like their
shape maybe their textures maybe
you know color etc etc so that's the
reconstruction problem in a way
you are in your head creating a model of
the external world
okay a reorganization is to do with
essentially finding these entities so
uh so it's uh organization
or the word organization implies
structure
so uh that in in uh perception
in psychology we use the term perceptual
organization
that uh the the world is not just
an image is not just seen as is not
internally represented as just a
collection of pixels but we
make these entities we create these
entities
objects whatever you want to call and
the relationship between the entities as
well or is it purely about the entities
it could be about the relationships but
mainly we focus on the fact that there
are
entities sometimes i'm trying to
pinpoint
what the organization means so
organization is that
instead of like a uniform
grid we have the structure of objects
so the segmentation is a small part of
that
so segmentation gets us going towards
that
yeah and you kind of have this triangle
where they all interact together
yes so how do you see that interaction
in uh sort of uh
reorganization is yes defining the
entities in the world
the recognition is labeling those
entities
and then reconstruction is what filling
in the gaps
well to for example see uh
uh impute some 3d objects
corresponding to each of these entities
that would be part of adding more
information that's not
there in the raw data correct
i mean i started pushing this kind of a
view in the around 2010 or something
like that
because at that time in computer vision
the distinction that
people were just
working on many different problems but
they treated each of them as a separate
isolated problem
with each with its own data set and then
you try to solve that and get good
numbers on it
so i wasn't i didn't like that approach
because i wanted to see
the connection between these and
if people divided up vision into
into various modules the way they would
do it is as low level mid-level and
high-level vision
corresponding roughly to the
psychologist's notion of sensation
perception and cognition
and i didn't that didn't map to tasks
that people cared about
okay so therefore i try to promote this
particular framework
as a way of considering the problems
that people in computer vision were
actually working on
and trying to be more explicit about the
fact that they actually are
connected to each other and i was at
that time
just doing this on the basis of
information flow
now it turns out in the last five years
or so
in the post the deep learning revolution
that this this architecture has turned
out to be
very uh conducive to that
because basically in these neural
networks
we are trying to build multiple
representations
there can be multiple output heads
sharing common representations
so in a certain sense today given the
reality of what solutions people have to
these
i i i i do not need to preach this
anymore
it is it is just there it's part of the
solution space
you